[Music]
Age, greet them, Jaramillo came out with your
briefing for today, Monday, July 19. You
may have noticed noise
coming from heaven in recent
weeks. This is due to exercises carried out
by pilots from the Los
Angeles area force base that will spread
throughout  the next few weeks more exactly
until august 6th more planes
will be flying to train them and the
training facility
north of the valley on the other hand
registration for the school
safety program begins tomorrow this program
offers before and
after school activities for children in gender
open until fifth grade these programs
will be available every day it only
costs 10 dollars per student for
more information to find a
complete view of participating schools
visit disney.com diagonal in Spanish
and if you have not yet been vaccinated and
are looking for one  clinic we tell you that there
will be several around the valley for the
whole week  na all
cisen establishments are
organizing clinics
starting tomorrow,
brindis and face high schools will also have
clinics this week for more
information on places and times
available to receive the vaccine
against cóver you can visit the
official website of the district  of health
and now we move on to the
weather forecast, a day with clouds is expected, the
maximum will be around 101 degrees and
the minimum 87 degrees, there will be a 40
percent chance of rain,
lightning, winds and storms
after two in the afternoon, small
chances  they will continue until
midnight drive carefully beautiful
day sal y jaramillo greets us with their
brief information on inclusion in
Spanish
[Music]